[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want dude what got you into
video games
oh damn uh that's interesting yeah i
think it's the music
which is an odd thing he's a big
musician no [ __ ]
yeah music julius music julian yeah what
was it tetris
that's a sick tetris is one of them yeah
i think it's because i would just hear
other kids playing them like in my
family like the little and i would just
like blame the music to video no just
play in the game like you'd hear the
game before you know what it is
and then you just go that sounds really
cool like chiptunes
level yeah and then i think if it didn't
have music i wouldn't have been as
interested
because it did i was like
what's your favorite game of all time
final fantasy 6
why six uh everyone loves seven comes
along i know everybody loves seven but
it comes all over
the [ __ ] blow but i think it was the
age i was when six came out
and that's why you love anything like it
catches you at a specific age
and that was just the most magical
adventure that i could
i guess like put myself in and be
convinced it was like real
yeah yeah that's tight that was zelda
ocarina of time for me oh bro
my game was absolutely [ __ ] lit
all creative time was magic man
temple was so hard you guys do you guys
played now though do you have time to
play now
i make time to play now oh pandemic was
pretty sick for
pretty sick for it i played that breath
of the wild that zelda breath of the
wild
how do you guys put the controller down
um it just eventually hurts my [ __ ]
hands too much so i just put it down
yeah what is the longest stint you have
done
oh dude grand theft auto online i don't
even tell you like an hour oh dude gta
line's
[ __ ] that's hard to put down and this
is when you're like playing
and then it's like you're hungry so then
you order food and then it gets you
and then you eat and then you play and
then you get all of your kids now you
order food dude my wife could walk by
the screen
naked while i'm playing golf with all my
i'm like get the [ __ ] out of the way
when gta first came out the [ __ ]
48 hours story mode no way 48 hours
legend wait which gta is there five
oh five yeah wait is it five yeah yeah
i remember i spent i think i i set time
aside for the release
yeah i did too i finished it three
straight days holy [ __ ] yeah
binged hold on i i i i binged 48 hour
play
went to sleep and then finished it
that's like me on reading harry potter
4. that is some nerdy [ __ ] get out of
here
we're gonna we're gonna cut that you're
saying yeah editor can we cut that i'm
trying to stay swag
that's why i keep game guys talking
about that's nerdy wizard tournament you
[ __ ]
i can't start series tv series unless
like i'm like i gotta see how many
you know days it will take to finish um
i can't start games on story mode unless
i have nothing else
like i really want to play you're gonna
i obsess so hard that i can't leave it
so like i just got on manifest on
netflix right because i had the stomach
flu so i was like the show
yeah because it was like not number two
on netflix right now what is that it's
cool
is this a tv show where this airplane
goes through like the bermuda triangle
and then like when they land
five years has passed so now they have
to kind of figure out how to do their
lives
uh kind of i don't know sometimes
there was there was a guy that went
through the move triangle and then like
he landed much faster than he was
supposed to or something like that but
that was
it was like a 40 minute difference
sometimes it's fun to edge tv shows
though
you purposely create your own
cliffhangers i can't edge oh
wait you mean like it's a climax but
there's clearly 10 minutes left that's
gonna have a resolution and you're like
stop
i'll watch it you [ __ ] monster
well that would mean because he has
tiger he has to edge
before then i don't know what it was
like i just like sticking to a
sleep schedule so like me and jill are
back and they'll be watching like sons
of anarchy and i'm like oh it's 10
and i'll turn it off like what the [ __ ]
are you doing there's 20 like 15 minutes
left in the show
i i got i'll figure it out tomorrow it's
more exciting that way nah
man for me i haven't hate you i have a
headache
my eyes are in pain and i'm like next
episode
yeah wow dude there's times howard
there's times i need to go
diarrhea and even though i'm on the
toilet i'm like no you're not gonna [ __ ]
for at least another 10 seconds
yeah i just my [ __ ] actually i do do
that what
that is true because it'll come out
better yeah yeah well one day we're
going to fight dude i'm going to kick
her out
i'm sick of it i'm absolutely sick of it
you edge your diet you punish your
diarrhea
sometimes not all the time not diarrhea
sometimes i like to wait sometimes i
like to see how you edge diarrhea now
all you have to do is it's already edgy
yeah
that's true but then you're like oh i
got to wash the dishes so i'm going to
try to wash
i have to poop really bad but i'm going
to wash the dishes as fast as i can and
actually i like to take my time when i
wash the dishes
how do you take your time so you know i
just want to see i want to
it's the engine [ __ ] you up nick yeah
dude it's edgy bro
you edged my dishes too you're on my
team right now like this morning i was
working out right and i drank some
energy drink and then the caffeine hit
i'm oh [ __ ] gotta take a [ __ ] i'm like
oh so you wanna take a [ __ ]
we're gonna take our time and i'm
purposely walk slower to the bathroom
and i'm like oh [ __ ] my butt oh i'm
gonna take it but my bowl can't take it
anymore and i sit on the toilet i'm like
let's see if i can hold for extra five
seconds yep
see when you're old you know how people
should
yeah it's because they're not doing this
you don't understand bro you gotta train
that [ __ ] you gotta turn that [ __ ]
i'm like the opposite as soon as i need
a [ __ ] i'm like where is the bush
actually i'm like that usually i'm like
i'm already in the house no but
sometimes you're in a different mood
yeah goes at his own wedding he's like
where's the bush
[Laughter]
he's holding his wife's hand
the worst is the worst is when you're
trying to get the key in the door
and you need the [ __ ] i think that's
when your gut relates to the sound
and feel the closer you get dude but
that's why you gotta train that butthole
yo you gotta train it i do like
edging it in order to get a cleaner [ __ ]
yeah that happens
because it's more developed and you know
yeah
[ __ ] are you guys talking
really gonna try to sit here and tell me
and joe and anthony about how you're
edging your [ __ ] and it's helping
you yeah
i don't do it all the time but sometimes
i do that for a while sometimes
when he said that i was like you're
youtube okay tell me if this is tell me
just believe me i'm so mad
if this is believable or not okay i used
to have a phobia of [ __ ] in public
restrooms so i could never [ __ ] anywhere
but home okay a lot of people don't have
that yeah yeah
i went to surf camp i didn't [ __ ] for
seven straight days
unbelievable hey mine's a powerful thing
i didn't [ __ ]
seven days i didn't even eat the [ __ ]
food i was eating kit kats
i have i have done that for camping as
well you know when you go camping with
both guys you don't want to take a [ __ ]
yeah so you spent like three four days
not [ __ ] yeah i have done that
before but seven
you you then on the got day
god created the earth the seventh day he
was just like
how big was that just you just earth
bended afterwards it's just
measurable in size was it caddy it's
like a chipotle burrito
but yeah that's my phobia of like
[ __ ] i couldn't [ __ ] and even then
like i didn't feel like i had to [ __ ]
even hold it you're just
stressed out desire to not [ __ ] in a
public restroom would negate
the temptation to [ __ ] cause i'm not
[ __ ] [ __ ] in there so i just wouldn't
even feel it
that's crazy yeah today to this day i
can still do that like if i if there was
nothing but a porta potty here
i would just not feel like [ __ ] ever
have you pooped here before no i haven't
it's a great bathroom i got over that i
just [ __ ] i got used to those at like
festivals and [ __ ] and raves
i refuse to shoot i can't house i only
[ __ ] in other people's houses
i think it's disgusting
he goes just to his neighbor's house so
he could take a [ __ ]
hey mrs kim yeah i will say if i find a
nice restroom
outlet and i like didn't need to take a
[ __ ] and i was like i'm gonna take a
piss
it's a really nice question i'm like i'm
gonna try and take a [ __ ] cheesecake
factory or
yeah nordstroms you hang your clothes i
can do that now
yeah yeah one of our favorite bathrooms
is the wind
hotel in las vegas it's good it's in
there solid dude it feels like
it's too rich to [ __ ] in yeah you feel
like you feel lavish bro
you know it's a really really nice
restroom the [ __ ] woman's restroom
and caesar's pal
shopping how do i know thank you
i'm [ __ ] going you know you know the
shops at caesars right
i [ __ ] have you know when you're
walking and a [ __ ] hits you like a diary
hits you out of nowhere like you're a
mid conversation
i now i'm a 10 out of 10. i have to take
[ __ ] emergency emergency [ __ ] i was like
yo i was with my friends
and i bounced on them and i just run
into a restaurant nobody's in there i do
remember walking quickly and thinking
like man these
vanity mirrors are beautiful yeah i go
into the restroom
next thing you know after i'm like
[ __ ] my pants around my ankles
i swear like a [ __ ] busload of people
got unloaded in the rest
no and everybody comes there's doors
but i am hearing what sounds like high
heels and like
female jargon or whatever and this is my
this is my ass i'm just finishing my
[ __ ]
i look down and i [ __ ] see girls
shoes so i pick up my heels because i
don't know why my big ass feet or
it feels uncomfortable i pick up my
heels my little
off the floor not my toes but the back
side of my feet
come off to pretend i swallow my feet
and i don't know what to do
for a long time i'm talking like maybe
15 20 minutes
today's video is brought to you by
amazon music
and you know they have more than just
music on amazon music
they actually have like over 10
million podcasts okay it's
that's so many podcasts i don't even
think if a baby
was born and started listening to every
single podcast on amazon
they won't even be able to finish it by
the time they're old
and ready to go away there's infinite
amount of content out there
and what i love about it too is it works
hands-free with your alexa
so one of my favorite things to do is
when i'm cooking in the morning i always
go
am i let's go alexa give me happy
breakfast music you should try that out
happy breakfast music yeah it's like
this chill like upbeat like
jazzy type of like make you want to cook
more eggs
it just makes you happy and like you
just you just feel like you're in like a
brunch
type environment that's you know you
just want to like toast the sourdough a
little bit nicer
it just makes you want to like put out
some butter it just puts you in a good
mood
and it's hands-free and i like that and
i also like it when i'm working out and
i'm jogging
and i could just tell alexa to do
whatever i wanted to do
so if you want to check this out for
free because you get to do that because
you listen to us
go to amazon.com off the record to
stream
over 10 million episodes of podcasts and
thousands of playlists and music
stations
go to amazon.com off the record to get
your free
music streaming and podcast streaming
and there's no credit card or
subscription required
just now you just gotta watch i'm trying
to just wait but there's there's a
constant flow of what seems like oh
convention traffic
at that window of a moment where
nobody's there right now because i say
[ __ ] it my friends are calling me but i
like
i can't pick up the phone bill hello you
know it's all just i'm ending the
conversation as quickly as possible
finally i'm like [ __ ] there's no way
everybody's waiting for me outside this
is the worst situation ever so
pull up my [ __ ] get ready to go and i'm
gonna go quick
open the door power walk through but
that's when like you like were there all
the women there well women are in there
they're just staring at you but
it's such a shock because like what is
this what the [ __ ] is going on was he
perving on him and
all i can do is power walk by i'm like
i'm so sorry you said that sorry i said
that and there's a row of chicks who are
sitting on urinals and we're like
it's a [ __ ] guy's bathroom the whole
time
you said i'm so sorry i didn't know
they're staring at you you have long
hair at the time you should have said
i'm so sorry i went into the wrong
bathroom versus
i'm so sorry and you walk out there like
for perfect on me
yeah yeah i don't know what to do when
it was like vegas so you know everything
is captured
so when i kept blowing all my friends
outside what the [ __ ] happened but i
didn't even talk to him because i didn't
want to be the culprit right outside
the scene right the scene of the crime
so i kept power walking all the way to
the end of the shots
like a hundred yards later a great
restroom though good great restaurant
great restaurant
way better than the man individual
vanity mirrors
wow individual you know how like we have
like a bar
yeah and then there's like sync one
mirror yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
individual [ __ ] sinks that look like
their own fountains made in cinderella
and [ __ ] with a single circle mirror
each like
i was like this is [ __ ] beautiful
after you aren't worrying about your
[ __ ] yeah
i was just in vegas and the guy's like
do you want a shoe shine and i was like
are you [ __ ] serious i was like you
wanna you
[Laughter]
just passing through friendo
yo the new finally they opened up
resorts world
that [ __ ] was being built for ages man
i wanted to go what i'm gonna stay there
you know resorts world right
it went through like three companies so
it was gonna be the biggest [ __ ]
project on the strip
in early two years in the philippines i
remember really have a resource world
there too yeah
yeah i think it's a malaysian company or
something asian company but
it wasn't gonna be that it was like
another i think it was mgm or
another company bought it went through
another one
they built that right during the
recession hit in 2008
and then they went [ __ ] under and
then they switched over a couple of
times
now finally sell me on resorts world
sell me on it what is it well it went
okay i
i i to me i don't even know where to
start
because it was a [ __ ] train wreck and
that's why i'm so interested in it
because it was supposed to be the
biggest craziest hotel in in las vegas
and i want to see
what they ended up doing with it because
the last time i checked
is they were starting to rebuild it and
i don't know what happened
yeah like what's supposed to be so crazy
about it it was supposed to be
china oh i know what you're talking
about now yeah yeah i saw that one the
red hotel
yeah yeah the red one yeah it was
supposed to be
[ __ ] little china in las vegas okay
yeah like china themed with the like
with the china roof and everything
and it switched over a couple of
companies and now it still has that
asian theme okay
but it's kind of bootleg
in my opinion it's it's a regular chat
yeah but i don't know
i saw the blueprints of it and it looked
like it was gonna be like [ __ ] kung
fu panda land
you know but now it's just a red
building yeah
yes kung fu panda land is great let's
keep perpetuating that one beat him to
the punch
cause my my whole thing was okay you
know back in 2008
and um a lot of at the time i don't
think
macau and the that [ __ ] was hot yet
um oh wow cause a lot of the you know
like wynn
um sans all these guys right
they're making way [ __ ] more money in
macau and china
than they are in vegas they don't give a
[ __ ] about vegas i think they recently
sold the uh the lvs
the las vegas sands um uh two hotels
what was it the venetian and the palazzo
yeah yeah it's done so vegas is just
kind of like
ah [ __ ] i don't really care about them
resorts world was supposed to be a place
where chinese billionaires would come
and play and it was catered to the
asian the public right but then now they
they already rebuilt vegas out of macau
all the same
hotels we have here when palazzo all
them
they're out there so they're like why
the [ __ ] would i want to go to vegas if
they have the same [ __ ] like
so vegas is kind of like catering to
just america literally you go to vase
all chinese people so you're like what
the [ __ ] is this
well in vegas in macau oh it's vegas but
uh
it's vegas about macau alternate reality
based shells right
yeah yeah the mgm grand all that stuff
and you're literally like
still asian elvis in middle street it's
all it's
it's vegas but it's all asian people all
chinese people
it's crazy it forgot me i actually felt
a lot safer really
yeah yeah really safer well it's cause
like you know it's a predict like
everybody's like the same thing
oh you know when you go to like the
strip in vegas if you like look on one
side where they got like the [ __ ]
tattoos margaritas and planet hollywood
everybody's like just [ __ ] like
raging
crazy you look on the other side it's
like the rich you know weird yeah
cosmopolitan the lv and the shopping
yeah so you see like people that's
shaking their heads up the fat tuesdays
people exactly
but in macau it's like all one people
and you're just like what the because
vegas you go to vegas for the melting
pot sometimes yeah yeah you're just like
the melting pot of degeneracy from those
exactly rich whales
all the way right down to the down and
out same thing
but that's also kind of what made vegas
vegas like just seeing everyone that's
what i noticed
when i just went there recently because
i haven't been as an adult really and
you see
all kinds of people all walks of life
it's so fun to people watch over there
oh dude i was walking through
uh by the poker room in the aria nikki's
in there playing and i was walking with
a wikileaks shirt on
and this guy's and this guy's smoking
his cigarette right and he's just he's
got his back against the wall and he's
like
that shirt's dangerous friend
and i'm like i know right and then he's
like he's like
he takes i'm not even kidding he takes a
track and he's like
right on brother
and i was like what do i even say this
and i was just like yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna
ride on i was like that's so stupid why
did i say that he was so [ __ ] cool he
smoked a cigarette
he told me to ride on and then i was
just like yeah i'm gonna go right on you
should be like
broom yes broom brother anybody in this
room could write a better line than what
i said i was so disappointed i'd be like
yeah and then walk away that's me you
see some funny [ __ ] though i remember me
and my friends were swimming at the
motel 6 pool
and there were these two senior citizens
playing poker and they got up and got
into a fist fight oh
[ __ ] over a game of cards and then the
security came and had to like break it
up
and do all that [ __ ] it was hilarious it
was the most slow motion fist fight we
ever seen
you guys were swimming at the moment i
was exposed yeah i mean
we couldn't afford much we were like
what 18 19.
and it's right behind the denny's right
yeah good danny's
i always go to the tuscany when i'm
feeling pretty broke tuscany mm-hmm
dude it sounds familiar yeah it's an all
sweet one right it's right next to hard
rock
yeah yeah what's the how much does it
cost like it could be 20 40 bucks
sometimes what the [ __ ]
and you get like a whole whole ass sweet
with a you just kind of walk like half a
mile to get to this trip but
it's nice have you ever stayed at vadar
before
there's no casino in that one right now
there's no casino but it's connected to
the aria it's like right
but it's great probably like cooler
because it's quieter maybe it is quieter
you hear people
yelling and all [ __ ] my goal is to stay
in every single hotel on the strip
same and so far i i'm i'm i'm i got
through all of almost all of them
yeah but except you said that certain
circus yeah i did circumstances
when they had that as a kid i probably
remember how i wanted to do that thing
with you where we
get the most biggest room in the
shittiest hotels
yes that would have been sick we were
researching
penthouses and everything and like
circus like the polo towers and [ __ ]
yeah
we're looking at all that we're sitting
in the links for weeks because i'm like
i wonder what it was like back in those
days because they were the top of its
games
the heyday hotels yeah there someone got
murdered there right that's cool there's
some history for sure yeah
you know sinatra's beating natalie woods
[ __ ] up in one of those yeah
it's advertised as such you know he's
right
[ __ ] landed they have a little plaque
it's all just crusty you're like oh
that's frank sinatra's jizz right there
no way that's [ __ ] weird hey those
are the stairs that fred astaire threw
ginger rogers down
fairy stairs you know all those classic
hollywood stories
was she okay that's where betty white
was sucking off dick van dyke and [ __ ]
guy's name's dick van dyke oh is that
why
they were [ __ ] betty white and dick
van dyke no i just made that up
i was like i feel like i was like oh
[ __ ] it's old bro
she's really old i'd always imagine dick
van dyke was way older than betty white
yeah me too
no did you guys see him in the new mary
poppins movie where he plays the old guy
again
but he's old now no
because he's still live cause you know
in the old one he did old makeup and
then the new one
he's just an old guy dick fan died dude
yeah it's pretty interesting